check out sponsors and nature's blend
they specialize in premium Ethiopian
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below like all my
homies are mixed yeah mix yeah I can see
that yeah
everyone everyone here see the thing is
I don't see none of that [ __ ] I don't
see clutter bro all I see is the people
inside the goodness in their heart bro
in order mean and in the end that's all
that matters well that's all that
matters everything that's outside it
started boys
we believe the Quran teaches us the
method of how to be good to the Creator
and one one other one never leave you
before you go is the person the
definition of true goodness is imagine
if you
but would you be a good present if you
abuse your mom always puts everybody
else wait like even if you abused
animals that shows that you're not good
you know what I mean you can't even do
that yeah there's a certain way even
when you eat an animal it saves them
from more pain because you can get it
off you know but just come to the main
point about your you said your mom you
feel about your mama come back to my
mind and I'm putting everybody else
everybody says Ali I'm an invalid by the
way and it's an amazing yeah cuz you
talk about goodness it is very important
is that this what we say that an analogy
I gave you between the mother and the
general public is that I believe through
goodness is that I could compete with
everybody but if I don't show gratitude
to the one who could probably create
shock if I don't show gratitude to him
and what is given to me it doesn't
matter what he doesn't matter what you
do it doesn't matter what nobody thinks
it works is I'm a good person but I'm
abusing the one who's giving me my
mother my health the food I eat the
drink and everything that I have around
you if I don't appreciate and value it
and don't spend your fooling yourself
you're holding yourself yeah it's people
tricked themselves to believing they're
good and realize look I'm gonna tell you
right now that I was born in a country
that has been in war the whole time yeah
we eat animals we don't bless them we
don't do it we just slaughter them both
and we just that [ __ ] people are
aggressive on her door I'll be the first
minute article I grew up in LA all my
life this is the city I grew up in yeah
and all I've ever known is violence bro
that's all I've ever known is violent
all my life you know I just seen gunshot
my friends getting killed people in jail
murders all kinds of [ __ ] I'm
desensitized to [ __ ] like it's um I'm on
a different level of how I see things
now because I've already been through
this [ __ ] dawg like it's I'm tired of it
I want peace in my life you know say I
say you're a good man yeah no no no no
from what we can see because looking at
it sometimes you can observe him you're
a good man you see you see what you have
a clean heart and you said you reached
it's some kind of a pinnacle he said
it's beyond religion here
I'm not gonna sit here look honesty is
the key to life dog and I'm not gonna
tell you I'm a good man I don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] too
well you know they were saying realizing
it's realizing you you did bad things
and what are you gonna do to make it
better
what see this is the thing like you know
I I read I listen bro I listen I listen
to what people say you know and really
you gotta tell yourself this what have
you done in your life that's made your
life better or made you better you know
as a better person a good person what
have you done in your life I've done a
lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in my life and I
gotta live with it you know and in the
end now like I'm not saying I'm the
worst person in the world you know but
in the end yeah I even though I was a
dancer I grew up in the hood dog you
know I I [ __ ] grew up around crazy
[ __ ] all my life dog people
shooting each other I know some crazy
killer people dog and and it's and and
that's just the way the life is out here
bro if you grow up in the hood that's
what you see man well I was saying this
a hundred percent right you know you're
a being very good person yeah but to
understand the true understanding of
goodness like we have a concept in Islam
called loving someone for the sake of
God what that means that's unconditional
I don't love you because if I give you a
gift I'm not giving you a gift
with expectation return that you give me
a gift that's not love that's really
expecting something we have this
unconditional addition exactly so we
exactly so we love someone for the sake
of God what that means is I love you not
because what you're gonna do for me I
just love you as a human being today I'm
trying to say and I think to understand
another concept of goodness is to read
the Quran like brother Muhammad said is
because then you understand another
paradigm of goodness because that's that
connection between you and your Lord and
you're building that connection with him
Judy I'm trying to say so reading the
Quran teaches that because God tells us
in the Quran how to worship Him yeah and
have that relationship with him and like
I said before man you know if you read
the Quran give it a chance you've got
nothing to lose I mean and you said that
you've done with mistakes in your past
if I'm not mistaken the Prophet peace be
upon him said all the children of Adam
sinned and the best of those sinners are
those who repent you know that's all it
says real we have made me since he's
made me say we all make mistakes but in
God's eyes
repentance what that means is that we
also have a hadith prophet peace be upon
him he said that the God Almighty said
that if human beings were not to sin I
will destroy them and bring forth
another nation
that sin and repent but the fingers hold
on a second what is God except it's good
encouraging us to sin know what he's
trying to say is you're going to sin
you're bound to sin but what you need to
acknowledge is this you have a lord
that's off forgiving me and you turn to
him and if I leave that would be I know
you're busy is a message I've heard
through most people who who are usually
religious like and and and and I it's
the same message you know it's not as a
way of life no no yeah oh yeah for me
you know I'm just saying from people
I've heard it from usually are from
other religions and they're usually
extreme religious people you know what I
mean so I'm not extreme like that yeah I
was raised Catholic but it's not and not
by choice yeah I didn't give you what
you are extremely you're extremely kind
they call me mark the spot
my name is Marcos though born and raised
in LA man and just you know yes oh here
we go
you know everything I learn dog has been
to dance majority of things I've come to
understand Susanne's exactly you know
everything everything I look man most
people have talked to me yes but
everything that has come to me yeah I
don't know where it came from bro the
thoughts just come to me and I know it's
the universe speaking to me you know so
I listen now because every time I
ignored it I made bad choices bro I mean
this is it yeah yeah yeah and I know I
know it is that's why I'm paying
attention bro that's why I let the
energy come to me because I don't I
don't reject things you know no more bro
I don't I don't know so take everything
in but I don't allow myself to not learn
something new because I know it's only
gonna make me better yeah you know so
when it's a universe speaking to do you
mean like these signs that you see and
everything what we say is this year like
I said you know when taken to another
level yeah
we believe that the Creator and that
created made this creation and he was
injured signs within the creation so you
should you could take your to another
level you can take another little find
that connection with God read the Quran
if you can be handy for nothing to lose
and then you realize that it wasn't the
creation but it was the Creator that was
using the creation to send you the
message yeah yeah it goes that will
certainly show them the science so it's
everywhere is an F fitty F F we showed
will certainly show them the signs in
the universe and within themselves until
they know it's the truth
I made too many mistakes already not to
listen you know enemy like so I I follow
my what I feel is best for me because my
look my half of my family was in the
military the other half was in gangs
from being a dancer bro yeah you know so
I broke that cycle from my family you
know I'm breaking a cycle now brought
where we're coming out of that because I
didn't decide to do with you you saw the
negativity because I was too look man I
have a lot of anger I know this it's
something I struggle with everyday world
but it has a lot to do with the way I
grew up I grew up in a very traumatic
life you know I seen a lot of violence
my parents were drug addicts [ __ ] you
know I told you guys [ __ ] dawg like but
in the end I don't let that determine
who I am you know what I mean in the end
this is who I am
people like you are an evidence for
those who say I was brought from this
life and and she a product of their
environment that's it because you have a
choice my parents were drug addicts bro
my [ __ ] family or having gangs and
you weren't in the military so there's
no excuse dog in the end it's your
choice
it's your choice but for me fortunately
I had people around me that led me to
that path
maybe that was the universe you know you
know what guiding well the one who
created the universe
yeah the creator you know that was him
yeah you know and and and he just guided
me and and and I was subconsciously just
not but now I'm consciously doing it now
I'm really listening now I'm like oh I'm
looking for the signs I look for
everything else cuz we're a Christian as
well laughing I appreciate we ask we ask
Allah to guide you God Almighty to guide
you and give you the best in this stuff
in the hereafter